Film Courage: Let’s suppose you finish…you
have this thing where you want to always finish
something [a screenplay]…but let’s suppose
you finish it and then you go back to it and
you’re like I’m not really that into it.
Do you just leave it alone?
But the fact that you finished it was mainly
what was important to you?
Todd Berger, author/co-writer of The HappyTime
Murders: I’ll always want to get it to a
point where I can show it to other people.
I’ve never done a first draft of anything
like “Meh?
I’m glad I wrote this but I’m never going
to show it to anyone.”
Because I feel you never know when you’re
going to meet a person who wants to do the
exact thing you had written five years ago?
So I always want to get a script to the place
where I would feel comfortable showing it
to someone else if it ever came up.
I don’t show it to people, I would read
it, I would be happy with it, I would show
it to my wife just to make sure it makes sense
and probably look for typos.
And then I’m happy to put it on a shelf
and never show it to anybody.
Unless one day I’m in a meeting, one day
I’m at a barbecue and someone’s like “Yeah,
I’m a producer.
My brother owns a furniture store in Arizona
and I’d love…I can get you a free location
and I have half a million dollars and if I
can find a movie set in a furniture store
if I can shoot there and that’s when I’m
able to say…”Funny?
I have a thriller that I wrote set in a furniture
store five years ago.
No one has ever seen it.
No one has ever read.
I just wrote it because I wanted to write
it, it was a story I wanted to tell but I
was very aware that there was no market for
a half million dollars furniture story movies
but then who knows?
The HappyTime Murders, D. Robertson and I
came up with these characters, came up with
the story, I wrote the script.
We tried to get it made for fun, we just wanted
to for fun and it didn’t happen.
Put it on the shelf, years later (we weren’t
doing anything with it), it was sitting on
a shelf (the virtual shelf of my computer).
My agent calls me, he says “Hey, the Jim
Henson company called me because they are
starting a new division called Henson Alternative
and they are looking to do grown up puppet
stuff and they called and they’re like We
want to develop an R-rated puppet movie, do
you have any writers who you think would be
a good fit to do that?”
And my agent said “Well actually I have
a client who already wrote an R-rated puppet
movie, it’s called The HappyTime Murders,
he wrote it like five years ago.
And they were like “What?”
So he sent it over and they read it and they
were like “Oh, yeah great, let’s do this.
That’s exactly what we wanted.”
But we had already done it just for fun.
So that’s always been my method it’s just
I write stuff for fun that I like and then
I put it on the shelf and maybe one day it
will come up in conversation and someone will
want to make it.
Who knows?
Film Courage: What makes it an R-rating?
What are these puppets doing that’s so grown
up?
Todd: The puppets are doing everything that
people do in their everyday life but we’re
finally seeing what the puppets do behind
closed doors.
What the puppets do on the streets.
How the puppets actually talk to each other.
I’ve written a bunch of family stuff, I’ve
written a bunch of PG movies.
But the movies I’ve directed have always
been R and they’re always filled with cursing
and grown up themes and people have asked
me “Why do you have these characters cursing
all the time?”
And I’m like “That’s how people talk.”
My friends (when we’re hanging out), that’s
how we talk.
And when you want to make a movie about a
certain kind of person, they curse a lot.
They drop swear words or this is how they
talk to each other and when we set out to
make a movie about the actual…what if there
was an actual world where puppets and humans
coexisted with each other and the puppets
were like this underclass of society that
were like these sugar addicts, living on the
streets and were this underclass, it would
be pretty rough and they would talk to each
other in pretty rough ways.
It would be a really interesting world to
explore and the funny thing about R-rated
comedies is that a lot of movies you see there
is this very fine line between PG-13 and R,
right?
And so it’s very easy to take a script and
be like “Why don’t we just make this PG-13?”
All you have to do is cut some swears out
of it.
But if you are going to commit to creating
an R-rated movie, a lot of times studios or
production companies will say “If this is
going to be R, let make it R. Let’s go for
it, you know?”
Because why not.
We’ve already committed to appalling to
a certain kind of audience that wants an R-rated
comedy and we’ve alienated anyone under
the age of 16 who can’t go see it unless
they are with a parent or guardian.
So we might as well go for it.
There is no point in making an R-rated comedy
that are going to have one or two swear words
and that’s why it’s R. Why?
Let’s just go for it and get nuts, lets
show the sordid private lives of puppets and
all the shenanigans they get up to.